[Musique]
donc atteint
l'eau siarrouy c'est une miraculée elle
a survécu à un attentat perpétré par eta
lorsqu'elle avait dix ans elle vivait
alors avec son père gendarme et sa
famille dans une caserne est à voir la
caserne était situé ici en 1987 à ce
moment là le groupe terroriste eta a
tout fait exploser avec une voiture
piégée qui contenait de 250 kg
d'explosifs il a tué onze personnes et
en a blessé 88
35 ans plus tard elle garde de cet
attentat des traumatismes psychologiques
ma mère à une mobilité très réduite à
cause de ça
donc l'avoir ne rappelle tous les jours
qui s'est passé c'est difficile de
refermer nos blessures alors que nous
sujet très actuel
le procès pour cet attentat vient d'être
rouvert à l'encontre de josu ternera
chef de thé à au moment des faits il est
actuellement retenus en france après une
cavale de seize ans la justice espagnole
demande son extradition pour déterminer
son rôle exact
il faut qu'il vienne au tribunal pour
répondre de ses actes en tant qu
autorité intellectuelle de l'attentât et
les tours dépend d'elle certes les
blessures ne s'effaceront pas mais
qu'ils rendent des comptes à la justice
ce ce qu'il mérite et c'est un pas
important pour location de machines
bolton t
eta a mis fin à la lutte armée il ya dix
ans mais 350 attentats attribués à
l'organisation comme celui ci ne sont
toujours pas résolus le souvenir des 850
victimes du groupe est toujours ancré
au pays basque la société reste
profondément divisé les proches des
prisonniers de pelé à se rejoignent à
bilbao lors de cette manifestation
indépendantiste
et pas comment ça va et ton fils il est
encore un prison comme les autres mais
il va bien
tous critiquent la politique
pénitentiaire d'exception appliquées il
y a trente ans par madrid les
prisonniers de théa étaient éloignés de
chez eux pour éviter les rassemblements
devant les prisons
des 174 prisonniers qui sont sur le sol
espagnol la moitié est encore incarcérés
en dehors du pays basque
maïder bissau et la femme d'un ancien
membre du groupe condamné pour trois
assassinats il est en prison depuis 21
ans selon elle il devrait être considéré
comme un prisonnier politique à la
capelle pendant qu'ils sont emprisonnés
pour des motivations et un conflit
politique
en fait on demande surtout est ce que
nos proches soient libérés
il n'y aura pas de co existence réelle
tant qu'on n'aura pas surmonté ses
rancunes qui demeurent après ce
qu'elle a fait
ces citoyens votent majoritairement pour
bild ou parti indépendantiste basque
plusieurs de ses membres étaient en
relation avec eta ou ses partisans bildu
est un allié du gouvernement de pedro
sanchez qui en a besoin pour maintenir
sa faible majorité une coalition qui
disent les espagnols
c'est inacceptable que le président du
gouvernement parle d'un front contre la
droite sans accuser les héritiers de
terrain de tous leurs crimes et de
manquement de respect envers la
constitution et les institutions
au contraire patxi lopez députés
socialistes basques se félicite de la
présence de bildu au congrès pour lui
c'est la preuve qu'un travail de mémoire
est en cours tu aimais galerie oboro
ils ont dû choisir entre des bombes ou
des volts ils sont ici grâce à la
représentation que leur donne l'envié
quand on marque par technibel plus ils
participeront à la vie privée plus ils
se rendront compte que la violence n'a
jamais de justification démocratie la
violence est donc en terrain connu
au pays basque cette volonté
d'apaisement et symbolisé par mail
shabelle l'aca son mari un ancien
gouverneur socialiste basque a été
assassiné par un commando de théa en
2001 mémorial pour lui rendre hommage a
été construit elle s'y rend
régulièrement
elle tenait donnera laisse avoir un
endroit concret où l'on puisse se
souvenir d'une personne est très
important
au coeur de la montagne cette scène
incarne son chemin vers la résilience
dans le carnet tout ce qu'ils ont fait a
été vain la seule chose qu'ils ont
réussi à produire c'est de provoquer
beaucoup de douleur vous toucherez
bientôt beaucoup de souffrance il faut
en parler et il raconté
mme aïcha ben elle a été l'une des
premières victimes a accepté de
rencontrer deux des assassins de son
mari ils se sont repentis et sa photo
cette photo a été prise quant à yvonne
et chez sarita l'un de ceux qui a
participé à l'assassinât de juan mari
est venu ici il m'a demandé quand il
s'est rencontré pour la première fois en
2014 s'il pouvait venir à l'un des
hommages je lui ai dit que ça ne me
posait pas de problème
cette justice restaurative lui a permis
d'avancer est détrempée avec le passé
son histoire est racontée dans un film
sorti au cinéma cette année preuve que
le thème passionne le long métrage a
attiré plus d'un demi million
d'espagnols dans les salles grâce à lui
maïssa bey l'espère raconté le conflit
pour que l'histoire ne se répète plus